[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  hello my name is officer Holden whodunit  in the court of law decisions of lasting  repercussions are often made based  solely on eyewitness accounts from this  point on I'd like you to rely solely on  your own memory and for the sake of the  exercise do not attempt to review this  video we will no I'm going to show you  some images of criminals matching the  description that you gave the police  earlier from these images I'd like you  to identify the man with the gun you do  that for me so think you know who it was  are you sure are you positive well based  on your eyewitness account we were able  to arrest this man Mike carry out thanks  for your help  you